while individuals such as myself having
confidence in the people we are and the
bodies we inhabit is not a proven
contributor to obesity in fact it's
shown that self-confidence can help you
make more positive behavioral changes
fat shaming on the other hand and yes
this includes health shaming especially
that of children and adolescents
is proven to cause further weight gain
and yes is recognized as a contributor
to obesity what i'm getting to you
tiresome trolls is that you in fact are
the ones promoting
obesity oh dumb facts is spicy this lady
is saying it's wrong for you to say it's
wrong to be super fat because you'll
encourage people to be super fat which
is wrong do you see how perverse that
logic is because i at least i get the
argument the main fat phobia argument is
no standards whatsoever don't you dare
tell anyone that they should put down
the cupcake the new
version that this lady is putting out
there is if you tell someone to put down
the cupcake they won't and that's bad